we bought Thornton coming in yes welcome
back to Jim Norton and Sam Roberts Billy
Bob Thornton coming in welcome man how
are you doing hello it's good to see you
yeah it's all good I was watching a I
watched the movie last night and I was
worried about it a little bit because
Bad Santa
by the way Bad Santa 2 is obviously the
movie and it comes out on November 23rd
and it's such like a gloriously mean
movie you know ii mean and they're just
not made anymore that you worry that
they're gonna do a sequel and kind of
especially now nice it up because I feel
like 2016 is nicer than 2003 was like
it's even tougher to get mean out there
and I was I was I was not even a little
bit disappointed it's [ __ ] hilarious
it really is funny and I think you guys
did a good job are you glad that you did
it oh yeah yeah do you respond better to
stuff like that that's a little harsher
like Christie knows there's nothing
worse than softer humor that's just like
it doesn't feel like it lands well I
mean you know the first one was kind of
created a sub-genre of comedy but sort
of the first one like that and and then
there were you know some imitators
afterward you know about a bad plumber
bad you know bad pet groomer and all
these different things and so but the
thing about Bad Santa is you can't just
go out there and be profane and be funny
you have to have something underneath
that yeah and so I think it always had a
good foundation you know and I yeah I
respond to edge your stuff usually I'm
not real big on I'm not I'm not the sort
of guy playing the dad next door that
you know whatever plays with dogs yeah
you know it's it's one of those things
where like you wrote a couple of things
and you direct them you said you don't
want to do that anymore because you felt
like they kind of took some of your
creativity way or they butchered what
your final product you wanted it to be
yeah a lot of times the stuff that they
shave off is the very
that you you need in there you know they
want to just keep close to the bone sort
of and I just tell the story and get it
over with and it's a lot of times it's
the character stuff and that's that
really gives something that's
personality
yeah and that's usually the first thing
to go and so but I mean as a director I
think I'm probably obsolete these days
anyway because I'm I was influenced
mainly by southern novelists and also
people like John Steinbeck and people
like that and you know I write stuff
that has humor and drama all mixed up
and these days that's popular for
critics to say what couldn't make up its
mind what it was it's like you know
that's the easy thing to say if
something has humor and drama if you
look at the classic movies most of them
do right and dramas often or just over
earnest and comedies are just wacky yeah
and you put them together and people
don't know what to think about it used
to be that was the norm and it's got
also be hard to get those movies made
right because it seems like everybody
wants to know exactly where does this
fit where do we plug it in or how do we
advertise it because would you sure
things only we only do sure things well
yeah I mean when I was a kid or teenager
or whatever James Taylor and Black
Sabbath were on the same radio station
right right and now it's like you know
everything is a compartmentalized
everything people do need to be able to
identify something and frankly I think
it's better when you can't you and I by
the way I don't know if I don't remember
but we did a tribute together the Ozzy
Osbourne that's right tribute all you do
okay so how did how did you know Ozzy do
you know him well or how you just mind
was he pretty well yeah you know I just
met him around you know it's like with
Lemmy I knew Lemmy and people say how do
you know with me it's like I don't know
he was a fan of something I did and I
just met him somewhere you know you just
meet people and and I knew Sharon I'd
she had a show it looks like her very
first show a long time ago I had like
the talk show kind of thing kind of like
Ellen has now and I was on there one
time and you know so I just kind of got
to know him and I just saw Ozzy when we
were shooting Bad Santa
he loves bad sad oh yeah
so I saw him up in Montreal my son
Willie was with me up there on the movie
and they were playing in Montreal we
went down to Psalm and Ozzy had some
kind of sinus infection or something
that night but yeah he's he was going to
come by the set and we're gonna throw
him in the movie and but he was you know
he got too sick with his infection and
had to go on to New York and yeah okay
you wanna give a little cameo yeah yeah
yeah I would have a nice would you've
enjoyed spending time on a movie set
with Ozzy Osbourne yeah it was like the
biggest I see fanatic I mean he's also
got a relationship with him now but he's
he's the biggest fanatic
I love how Ozzy's uh uh uh he has
remember this one he got a new car as
one of those you could had voice
commands or whatever yeah it's like
radio on and stuff like that I couldn't
understand never did any of the stuff
yes you got this all this technology
that he just can't use these noise for
whatsoever yeah I've watched him text
before and he still use it like a little
stylist to text I don't think he's a big
tech guy pretty Esther uses a stylist
yeah that's so funny I don't think he's
a big big voice command guy do you think
about the the reception that when you do
a movie or whatever it is that you're
doing like do you think about the way
it's going to be received like you sit
there like all people are gonna like
this or not like that or or you just do
it you know what the thing about it is
certainly not while I'm doing it I don't
think about it afterward you kind of
forced to because then you go out and do
press for it and you start thinking
about it but one of the things that I've
talked to friends of mine who have been
around a while after you once you're a
veteran of this business you know
exactly what's going to happen you do oh
yeah you know I can do an interview with
a guy and and or a girl or to be you
know fair yeah because every now and
then I can read women not real you male
Jews have you I've had a few miscues in
a short term though you can be very good
in the moment
exactly and but I told her a writer like
two days ago in LA he said something
about that and I said oh yeah I said I
can walk in a room and I can tell you
exactly who I don't want to hang out
with and who I do I can tell you you
know what people think of the movie yeah
he said really what do I think about it
and I told him and he said well you're
right
do you like it or not like it he did
okay good did but with qualifications
huh
Yona mean yes like here's what you think
I told him exactly what he thought and
he said yeah that's how'd you do that
nothing I you know I've been old man
yeah and I've been around I've seen you
guys for a long time but you can do a
press conference and get a vibe right
you know exactly if it's going to be
poor medium or great
what's it indicator to you that like you
go in and sit down with somebody that
interview that that's just going to be
[ __ ] like like what's what's it what's a
little tell for you that you'll just saw
it immediately you know what it's a
tonal thing it's it's a vibe it's not
really the questions so much because
especially impressed junkets people will
often ask questions that are straight
out of the what do you call it the idea
to know the the you know like the the
like the little bit Roche or whatever it
is I get out yeah and it's got quotes
from all of us and stuff and so you
don't like Twinkies huh
that kind of stuff and it's like yeah
that's right I sure don't and uh you
know it's stuff like that so you kind of
sometimes also if they get their
interview over with really kind of
quickly and oh thank you very much for
you know and but it doesn't necessarily
mean anything if they tell you they love
the movie right they a lot of times you
can be talking some one who doesn't say
anything about what they thought about
it but they just ask you the questions
and you know some other stuff about your
career sometimes the one will say oh by
the way it loved it and it's like you're
you're so foolish
you know yeah you know you can just like
let the door hits in there you know
their line yeah yeah you feel when I
just told you that I like the movie when
you came in did you think I was being
legit I believe here okay good
no I clearly believe you yeah not when I
said he walked in this morning you say
but I mean I can just look at you and
know that you like this I only have to
say a word okay
there's a fan and we know each other
already yeah yeah he uh I'm most
fascinated with the fact that Dwight
Yoakam was based on your your dad like I
am sling blade that's pretty I like his
what I love about that so much is the
character was really a really unlikable
guy but he wasn't so horrible that he
seemed cartoonish I made up it was
almost like he that's a real guy do
anything you didn't make some so abusive
they made him a human I saw him I made
him a person and what a mitten him an
[ __ ] and I kind of felt bad when he
got killed but I kind of it was just
really that was great yeah Dwight did an
amazing job in that thing and but yeah I
mean he was only based on that part of
my dad my dad wasn't that bad all the
time but you know I've done several
characters that I used bits and my dad
my dad was a high school coach so when I
did Friday Night Lights that was you
know easy one and there was a little bit
of mr. Woodcock and my dad you know so
uh and a character monsters ball it was
another character that I actually
channeled my dad and in terms of his
manner like his just the way he looked
and the way he walked and everything
else he was enjoy drinking my dad oh
yeah oh gosh no no my dad was it wasn't
I mean I remember him drinking a couple
of times that functions he had to go to
and he couldn't handle it you know yeah
I didn't come from a drinking family
other than one of my uncles it was kind
of like the character in beds then but
yeah they weren't real drinkers my folks
when you I did first of all did they
ever try to get you for that Friday
Night Lights TV show knows I know that
they grabbed a couple people from the
movie I would assume that you wouldn't
have done it because no it doesn't
strike me as something that you would do
um but like in the Friday Night Lights
role when you know that you have to play
something because that the coach in that
movie is very kind of
even-keeled and played down right do you
like doin energy you wish you had those
kind of moments where you can be more
outward well you know just a bit acting
for me whatever the situation calls for
is what you do and then in that case no
that's exactly what I wanted to do he
was based on a real guy
you know Robert Duvall said sending the
years ago he's been a mentor to me and
and he he said something that really
struck me it's a real popular thing to
say
with you know critics that oh this
person or that person is a wonderful
actor because they're so underplayed and
so understated well in fact life's not
like that I mean you know look at you
know some of the characters you see in
real life like in politics or whatever
it is you know there are moments that
you might do something as an actor and
something that that a critic like who
thinks that might say oh that was over
the top but life is over the top and
life is subtle sometimes and Duvall tell
me one time you said there's a very thin
line between subtle and boring yeah and
sometimes you know you see people just
you know do the sort of actor voice for
two and a half hours and it's like yeah
come on dude you know and it's like yeah
Suze one more thing I know I'm a man but
I'm pregnant or whatever it is it's like
no after two and a half hours that
you're like you know every now and then
yell at somebody will you yeah yeah and
like actually figure out if this
character is not just be this that
sounds like to just do it one kind of
dream line deal yeah right and there are
times when it's called for and it works
I mean you know examples in my career
but in the man who wasn't there the Coen
Brothers and in Fargo was going to ask
you about Fargo because how did you know
because you do Fargo how did you know
that that would work for the same
reasons that you wouldn't have done the
Friday Night Lights TV show do you know
what I mean
it wasn't this rehash of this great film
but something new that would I mean you
can probably tell by looking at me I'm a
massive Fargo fan too but it's like it
turned into one of the best seasons of
TV ever that was that was a real
decision to make I mean you know I
those guys the Coen brothers have worked
with him several times and they're
friends of mine and and I did make a
call and asked him if they were cool
with with it you know getting their
blessing if you will and they what it
meant something to me is when I read the
script and they did say yeah yeah we're
on board of this I read the pilot script
and it was really good I mean it wasn't
something that you had to go in there
every day and think I got to fix this
scene I'm a little bit yeah I just did
what was there the only thing I brought
to the character was they he was
probably they were probably expecting a
little bit more out there bad guy you
know probably a louder bad guy but early
on there was something in the writing
that told me this guy was a sort of a
ghost it's like is he real or not
is it gonna disappear one day yeah it
was yeah you really didn't know what to
make of it at first and the scene like
at the end in the Elat when he knows
that he's been found yeah like that
scene where you see real like you see
finally some real emotion like you're
really angry yeah that you've been found
and you left this guy behind that whole
life is over yeah and now you have to
actually deal with this there's just
this one like those little moments where
you're like exactly and he's that's who
he is that's who he is as a person he's
furious excited he has to deal with this
now and he becomes very murderous very
quickly yeah yeah and as a killer he
knows that he has to be a ghost he has
to be an animal because he really he's
the perfect example of a human being
being as close to the animal kingdom as
you can be yeah you know he actually is
kind of a wolf and he'll sneak up on you
and if you mess with him in an elevator
if you happen to be a bystander he will
just take care of you and Martin Freeman
was was was perfect as the guy to take
on you know there were William H may see
like traits but it wasn't too similar
that you were like oh I get what they're
gone for exactly no I did a great job
and I also want to again to not to jump
around too much but the fact that you're
afraid of antique furniture I think is
the grave error is that that's a real
thing yeah it's a not afraid of it as
much there's a definite phobia I'm
creeped out by it and not all of it
it's just certain things like for
instance I some of my phobias I don't
understand why everybody doesn't have it
yeah I mean it's like you know those old
wheelchairs you'd see back in like the
1920s and stuff
yeah yeah kind of wicker on the hood
stuff you know who wouldn't be creeped
out by that thing but it's just
interesting from a guy like you know
years ago you were notorious for having
you know blood locket with your with
your wife at the time right and then to
go forward and be like well here's what
creeps me out
cuz through a lot of now that's that was
like oh these are the creepy people over
here and you're like no no I don't like
[ __ ] wicker wheelchairs yeah they
don't creep me out I find them a little
I but they don't creep me out and make
me uncomfortable like where it was like
a castle you know like to go in a castle
with all the mildew and the moss on the
wall those big old creepy chairs with
the velvet on the stuff I couldn't eat
around that is it about ghosts and
people being dead no it's it's like a
sling Rose injure me yeah it's like guys
can you clean off a place for me to eat
here alright I can't do this and it just
creeps me out cuz there's no reason to
hold on to furniture for that buy some
new furniture
yeah cuz that doesn't have all the [ __ ]
on it that's been piling over there for
years yeah that's so it has nothing to
do with the fact that there have been
dead people on there about it's just
because it's so old I mean let's say I
go into a rag shop and I see a really
great I don't know deep purple shirt
yeah that's from the day yeah and then
it's on a rack with a bunch of other
dusty old shirts and I buy it I go home
and I wash the thing up you know three
or four times you do it yeah I'm not
going to wear that thing you know Roger
used to wear it you know and Roger like
no telling you see you don't like jars
are you a handshake are you like
chickens I'll shake hands but then I
immediately use the purity oh yeah yeah
it's a understand certain phobias like
Heights I'm afraid of heights and I get
why people be claustrophobic but then
some of the other ones I find her you
know you're not a Jeremy guys no I
probably I was you had wear condoms yeah
yeah about to say your personal well to
be deeply affected Jeremy guy as
no you know it's weird because you know
when you sign stuff for guys in the
streets you know like I'll autograph
people you know yeah I I have a real
problem because I'm a germaphobe in a
way and at the same time I'm codependent
so it's like a really bad deal because
just now we came from a TV show right
well I sign all all the ones I can get
to you know I sign home and everything
and then I get in the car and I wiped my
hands down and then a couple other cats
that come up on the skateboards or
whatever next to the car cuz you know in
New York in Li you get a wife people
really yeah you know here you can't get
away right so you're stuck on on a block
there and then three or four cats show
up at the window and you know I'm gonna
do it because I like I said I'm
codependent so I roll the window down
I've just I've just used the Purell now
I think the other guys pen I write some
other stuff up and roll the window up
use the Purell and then another cat
shows up instantly and I do his too so I
have to use a lot of lotion you know
yeah just destroying all that all the
antibacterial exactly you got to bring
your own markers have a silver and a
black in your pocket and some of your
own I know I usually do but you know
what's weird about it I don't know why
this is I guess it's then you know that
it's I don't to tell you trees I don't
know why I've never asked but most of
the autograph cats want you to use a
blue pen they do have that in their
heads they have this vision what the
autograph should look like it's a blue
pen but there's a reason for that
somebody maybe told me a long time ago
but I don't remember I don't remember
what it is either but I know when I see
I've seen like you know a Joe DiMaggio
photo that's supposed to be old signed
in a blue pen I'm like Jesus could that
look more [ __ ] forged oh you know what
I swear to god this happened I'm making
Friday Night Lights uh-huh
and first of all us Tim McGraw and I
signed a girl's dad's artificial leg
which was with she had a garbage bag the
way the dad wasn't went there was no
noise she brought his leg yeah hope she
watched the stump part right yeah and oh
this is a full-on had a foot inner ring
so anyways but
you know just speaking of this whole
forgery idea this guy comes up to me and
he says look I've got a lot of posters
I'm really sorry about this but I've got
like every movie ever made practically
and and if you'll sign these for me and
he gave me some story about how I don't
know what was going on yeah he had a
dandruff or whatever I don't know but
anyway so but he said I know this is a
lot to ask but I'm going to give you
something that I've had for a long time
that I really treasure he said I have
this drumhead signed by like all these
legendary people and and I'd have
glanced at it I saw Merle Haggard and
Johnny Cash and Waylon Jennings and it's
amazing all these people he'd had you
know for a while I didn't pay much
attention at the time so I signed the
guys posters I'm like that's cool a
guy's given me something with some
coasters so I take it in my trailer pull
it out of its a bag there it's a brand
new drum head first of all and obviously
signed by the same guy it's all the same
Henry Stimson oh yeah
and he just cherished this for years for
years yeah for moments cherish this for
moment sure as long as it took me to
write all these names back in the car 20
minutes ago well hanging with three g's
y'all look closer I said Merle Haggard
what a bummer yeah so shitty like just
be honest about what you're gonna do
with it a lot of times they want to sell
it so a lot of times if you ask them we
can help you who do you want it to the
just silent you should've told him it
would save you a lot of time just fake
my name on all these posters yeah
there's nothing from here right exactly
would have been fine how many were there
like dudes gotta be a 10 or 12 you
design oh he probably handed me there
must have been 16 17 of them yeah good
sport yeah guys would assign all that is
that it seems like in all the interviews
I've read that you've done you're not a
big guy on the fame culture like you
don't like being famous but I guess you
like having fans oh I love the fans I
mean my the fans that I've got I'm in
music and movies I mean you know they're
I don't have the
a number of fans that like say you know
Tom Cruise or somebody has but I mean
the ones I have I really dig them you
know yeah and so that I don't mind my my
main thing is a sort of social life of
being a part of Hollywood and that kind
of things like I don't get out much in
other words you know like every I don't
go to every you know Midas muffler
opening I have I mean or whatever it is
is like hey I want to be there too you
know I just kind of don't go anywhere
I'm not the see and be seen guy not
really I I get I'm still embarrassed by
a lot of it frankly you know like being
on a red carpet in everybody yelling
your name it's embarrassing to me do you
get afraid now you and I obviously
different levels of success but I'm
always terrified when I'm on a red
carpet I just want to go like please
take my picture I'm always afraid I'm
going to walk on and no one's gonna take
my photo and it should be humiliating
it's always a great opportunity to be
totally humiliated yeah that's a it's
true when they say does it bother you
and you know people do this but it's
like no it would bother you if they
didn't I guess you know but uh I mean I
don't mind it I'm just saying that I I'm
still actually embarrassed by it because
you know you you grew up B I'm still
pretty insecure guy you know and I
always think what the hell with these
people care about me for and then and
then you get there and they yell at your
name and it's like I don't know how to
it's like I was never a strip club guy
because I didn't know where to look does
that make any sense yet because you were
you were you were insecure but you were
shy you didn't want to write anybody
like am I supposed to be looking go look
her in the eye look down there it's like
lying oh I can't do that that's weird
you know and I said and then you see the
really creepy guys that you know are
there every day and you feel like one of
them and you know I don't know
so I also never knew how to have the
posture of a famous person if that makes
any sense yeah I don't know how to do
that I don't have that swagger uh-huh I
know how to just stand there like a dope
and let them take me I mean but I don't
really know how to do that that thing
like I'm uncomfortable run rich people
know like you go to Abbey
party it like some gigantic mansion and
everybody's got that attitude and
they're all talking about their favorite
ski resorts and stuff just don't know
how to be the guy right I mean I grew up
I was a dirt bag I mean one of my you
know now look at me I mean so I mean not
a dirt bag but I mean you know I was
grew up poor and I didn't have much and
then yeah you get famous then all sudden
you get money and then you're supposed
to know how to act I still don't know
how to act
I keep getting afraid that people are
gonna find out I'm not I don't belong
like I'm gonna be in the middle of
talking to some people who are
entertainers whatever and then someone's
gonna walk in and go he's a fake and
we're gonna oh my god you are I thought
that before it's like after 36 years
this business business I think someday
somebody's gonna walk up and say you
know sir there's been a terrible we all
realize you weren't supposed to get in
here you know
that's insane - we can't really think
what about all this stuff I've done yet
doesn't count any validation but erasing
it over no no you were supposed to get
that yeah and they said we have to wrap
up because he has other I guess Travis
he has other things yeah he's got a
couple other interviews too you know
it's interesting though because this is
d-bag you know he works for us yeah and
he wanted you to sign something for him
right but then I told him a quote that
you had once said recently which was oh
and I love the quote well what you on
the sign first of all a sleeve a post oh
you want it okay that's cool right now
of course because you'd said sure I'll
sign your Slingblade DVD and you can go
home and [ __ ] missionary can like a
metronome and never have an original
creative idea in your life no that was
in reference to people who bring
Slingblade posters for me to sign when
were in concert when I'm playing on tour
of the band oh I see see that's that
yeah it's it's when it's enough in other
words you're off his bread words you go
up and you do a two-hour show yeah and
you come offstage and you know you're
selling your record and you know I'm not
we're not we never expect to be Bruce
Springsteen look you know this is the
only way we've and are able to tourist
selling these records and the posters
from you know
that we sell it to shows you know yeah
and so I don't mind signing the movie
stuff to the people but if but if
they've got a stack of Sling Blade
posters and you just did it to show
right and they might not even have come
to the show right you know I mean right
and you're sitting you're trying to do
this and you're you're right exactly
yeah do you that's what I was we were
hoping you'd rip it up in a stupid face
no no I was really hoping I'm half into
sighs rustling whoa poster
do you know something anybody named
d-bag got you got a good what a great
man he's our Thurman Merman arm is hair
and see if we can get the same look I
love that do you right before you go do
you regret it all in the same music no
because I just thought of it that that
interview that you did that went viral
and and and everything you know man in
Canada oh yeah yeah do you regret that
you got it so visibly annoyed or was it
the exact same thing that you were
trying to do your music and it wasn't
100 respose weird about it was that I
was vilified and not this cat that's
what I didn't understand it's like
because you know the way they write
about that incident which is first of
all I couldn't believe it was news and
the second thing is that supposedly I
went on a rant and I barely was audible
you didn't say no I was just kind of
sitting there I mean I you know I went
nuts and I was on drugs and all these
things like no that didn't happen right
you know you didn't see what really
happened what happened went on before
you know and all I was saying was I'll
talk about whatever you want I don't
care I'll talk about I don't mind
talking about movies all I said was can
you do me a favor because it says on
your teleprompter there that you're
going to introduce this as Academy
award-winning actors here with his band
and I said would you show some props to
my guys here and just introduce us as
the band and then let's talk about that
that's all I said Wow
that's all I said and said and they said
yeah sure no problem
and then I saw that they didn't take it
off there and I said again look I'm
could you tell the guy to the producer
could you tell the guy just make sure oh
yeah that's just for reference don't
worry about it we'll never do that to
you
first thing looks me right in the eyes
is
like basically like I'm gonna stay at
however I want to and so that's what
happened that makes it and so instead of
you know walking off or storming out or
saying something about that I just
decided well you know what I'll just
answer your questions with other answers
yeah I can [ __ ] with you two then
you know yeah it was one of those things
it's like if a dude comes up to you and
just says here I'm going to knock the
rock off your shoulder and then you know
I'll pee on your shoes when people
aren't looking you know yeah exactly why
do that with my face is available
exactly well it was very simple yeah
make sense yeah and he and I saw him
later on and he came and he was very
nice to me said you know we kind of made
peace over uniquor okay good
well see bad Santa - it's in theaters
November 23rd and and you do know I
don't think you would do a sequel to
this movie if it wasn't good I would not
I don't think you would and it was it
was very very funny there's a lot of
good people in it so check it out Billy
Bob Thornton doing a pleasure man thanks
I was just great dude